eine Heilbronner Richterin die
35-Jährige Julia Schmidt hat jetzt
erstmals eine Haftstrafe verhängt einer
der Kleber der 22-jährige Student Daniel
e hat 48 mal Straßen blockiert jetzt
muss er für 5 Monate ins Gefängnis nach
dem Urteil sagte er ich will nicht ins
Gefängnis diese Strafe macht mir enorme
Angst trotz allem bleibt dabei schlimmer
als eine Haftstrafe sei eben der
Klimawandel Herr frei die Gerichte
greifen jetzt hat durch auch ihr
Parteivorsitzender hat bereits gesagt
dass sei richtig sehen Sie das genauso
wie Friedrich Merz ja absolut ich meine
jeder von uns muss sich ein Recht und
Gesetz halten anders funktioniert eine
Gesellschaft nicht und wenn es Menschen
gibt die sagen meine politischen Ziele
sind wichtiger als Recht und Gesetz ich
muss mich an Normen an die sich alle
anderen zu halten haben nicht halten die
verabschieden sich aus dem politischen
Diskurs und deswegen glaube ich brauche
es hier eine klare Kante der klare
Ansage polit wir haben Gerichten nicht
zu sagen wie sie zu urteilen haben aber
ich will nicht verhehlen dieses Urteil
in Heilbronn finde ich sehr konsequent
sehr richtig weil es im Grunde genommen
die Spielräume die der Gesetzgeber gibt
auch ausschöpft und das ist richtig so
viele sagen bei Prügeleien bei großer
großer Aggression da wird oft das
Strafmaß gar nicht so ausgeschöpft ist
aus ihrer Sicht so eine Strafe jetzt in
diesem Fall gerecht absolut gerecht ich
hätte mir viel mehr gewünscht dass
Polizei auch die Befugnis bekommen hätte
solche solche Vorfälle insgesamt zu
verhindern nämlich durch
Unterbindungsgewahrsam wenn wir hier in
Berlin beispielsweise versteht dass ich
hier Camps bilden um den Berliner
Straßenverkehr zu blockieren und damit
auch Rettungswege zu blockieren würde
ich mir sehr wünschen dass Polizei dort
präventiv tätig werden kann nach
bayerischen Vorbild bist du 30 Tagen
Unterbindungsgewahrsam natürlich auf
richterliche Anordnung um diesen Klima
Chaoten dort von vorne rein das Handwerk
zu legen wenn es dann doch dazu kommt
dass dort Straftaten begangen werden
verständlich hohe Haftstrafen ist das
einzige Mittel ich glaube über
Geldstrafen lachen die Knaben weil das
zahlen die Organisation die dahinter
stehen und der Haftstrafe lang genug die
weit über das über den Jahresurlaub
eines einzelnen hinausgeht das ist doch
empfindlich
und Kollegen der Polizisten die da im
Einsatz sind wir haben heute auch Bilder
aus der Hauptstadt gesehen da musste die
Feuerwehr durch da müssen die Beamten
und werden versuchen eilig die Straße
irgendwie frei zu kriegen wie groß ist
der Frust der bei der Polizei
also man darf ja nicht vergessen allein
die Berliner Polizei hat glaube ich
bisschen bislang um die 300.000
Einsatzstunden da drin investiert
irgendwelche
Chaoten mit Speiseöl von der Fahrbahn zu
holen also glaube ich nicht ausführen
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch bei
der Berliner Polizei die würden viel
lieber ihren Job machen und anderen
helfen also polizeifreund und Helfer
kommt hier überhaupt nicht mehr zum
Tragen weil eine Hilfe jemanden von der
Straße los Mann der sich selbst
natürlich angeklebt das ist nicht das
Verständnis was wir eigentlich von
Polizeiarbeit haben deshalb sage ich mal
wieder sondern Unterbindungsgewahrsam
muss her damit von vorne rein von
vornherein die abschreckende Wirkung da
ist das sowas unterbleibt also die erste
Haftstrafe herrschte was glauben
sie einem Menschen fünf Monate hinter
Gittern das kann ich nicht sagen aber
was ich sehe ist dass sich die das
Interesse dieser jungen Leute entfernt
von denen Dingen die ich für
verhältnismäßig und angemessen hatte man
ist es ja richtig dass man sich für
Klima einsetzt aber das größte Schaden
den ich glaube ich verursachen ist der
für die richtige
klimaaktivierung also wir müssen
aufmerksam sein ich muss mehr gemacht
werden aber damit diskreditiert man
eigentlich ja diese wirklich wichtige
Aktivitäten und ich hoffe doch dass auch
daraus gelernt wird und ich hoffe dass
man auch angemessene vernünftiger und
doch notwendiger und wirksamere
Maßnahmen findet sich wirklich politisch
dann auch vielleicht zu aktivieren dann
die Entscheidungsträger sitzen ja ganz
anders sie sitzen ja nicht die
Polizisten die dort das Öl auftragen
sondern die Entscheidung werden immer
anders gemacht aber ich muss mal sagen
das finde ich jetzt gar nicht so
schlecht dass die viele Menschen gegen
sicher aufbringen im Prinzip die
Bild-Zeitung und die Welt zusammen die
könnten nicht so viel erreichen wie die
selbst machen ja weil praktisch auch mal
eine breiten Bevölkerung zeigen was es
für Spinner sind das ist ja
sektenähnlich organisiert insofern auch
wenn ich mich Ärger darüber es hat aus
meiner Sicht durchaus eine positive
Nebenwirkung weil jeden Tag immer mehr
Leute sich genervt sind und sich
aufregen über diese Menschen und das
finde ich gut
die klimaaktivisten über diejenigen die
wirklich eigentlich was richtiges
bewegen wollen die haben ja den
Kollateralschaden dadurch und deswegen
glaube ich der Schaden den Gesetzen
größer als das was anwirkung heraus also
ich persönlich bin auch z.B schalte
genauso wenig von Fridays for future und
so die haben jetzt andere Methoden ja
und die haben ja Angst deswegen auch das
dass es ihnen schadet ja aber ich finde
es ganz gut weil auch diese Freiheit ist
future Leute die haben ja keinerlei
realistische Vorstellung ich habe mir
jetzt mal die Mühe gemacht es gibt ein
Buch von der Kreta tunberg dass sie mit
18 anderen Autoren geschrieben hat das
hat 500 Zeiten ich habe die 500 Seiten
gelesen ich habe auch darüber
geschrieben ja da findet man keine
einzige Lösung man findet nur lauter
antik Minimalismus muss der Kapitalismus
abgeschafft werden alle vernünftigen
Lösungsansätze ob das Atomkraftwerke
sind aber was auch immer die werden alle
verworfen natürlich jedem empfehlen lest
mal so ein Buch wie von der Kreta
Thonberg weil dann zeigt dass der Kaiser
ist nackt steckt einfach nicht dahinter
sie sind schon richtig drin in ihrem
Thema einmal möchte ich vorher noch über
die Frage auch bei Ihnen abholen Knast
also für die Klima Kleber halten sie für
eine gerechte Strafe alles sollten vom
Gesetz gleich sein gleich behandelt
werden aber ich glaube nicht dass man
mit Strafen die müssen auch sein dieser
Sache beikommt weil das Problem ist dass
die ja eine Ideologie die insgesamt in
beiden Teilen der Gesellschaft vor
vorher dass die die nur in extremerer
Weise zum Ausdruck bringen und die Leute
die glauben auch subjektiv daran wenn
ich jetzt glauben würde als junger
Mensch in wenigen Jahren geht die Welt
unter und ich muss jetzt was tun um die
Welt zu retten dann kann ich auch
verstehen wenn dann jemand sagt er klebt
sich auf der Straße fest also Strafen ja
aber ich halte es für Illusion wenn man
meint dass man primär damit den Ball
kommt würden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie